finally here we go good evening here oh
you have 500 and the dick popular
combination - I can keep that - yeah son
fit me some plays only retreat next
mission will call you all right
it's not a hug from - scram the top way
all right there yet
all right good good luck out there any
eight last year home nation very wet I
went for me
whoa that was awesome don't spare me
don't mess up I kill you every what do
you want you move them or not
I'm just kidding auger by
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocols because once
you start treating me like a kid
could you are a kid yeah you can stop a
boss with his bare hands
what's going on everybody so you guys
asked for some new Marvel we got all
this iron man iron spider suit going on
in the Marvel Universe right now so I'm
going to talk about the origin of the
iron spider suit in the comics and how
the MCU version is different the really
cool thing I think that they did with
the movies is that they fixed a lot of
the problems that were inherent with the
original iron spider suit in the comics
just really awful color design even
though it was a really cool idea when it
debuted way back during the original
Civil War there's a new round of the
spider-man giveaway it's for the action
figures all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so a lot of the stuff that you've
already seen in Civil War and what
you've seen in these trailers is
actually pretty true to the origin of
the iron spider suit in the comics it
just has all the basic functions that
you would find in an Iron Man costume
that he slowly discovers throughout the
original Civil War comic book until he
finally comes to the conclusion that hey
man this just isn't me I need to go back
to the classic there were a lot of other
reasons for that but based on the
footage we've seen so far from Spider
Man homecoming that basic arc plays out
in a slightly less contentious way so
during the original Marvel Civil War
spider-man had been living in the stark
tower he'd been in the avenger for a
long time and in the lead-up to Civil
War during amazing spider-man number 529
he gets up in the middle of it I can't
sleep and goes finds Tony Stark in
another room working on something
special hey there kid I'm working on a
couple upgrades for you what's wrong
with my old suit nothing only that it's
made of cloth the Iron Man of this 2007
Civil War era was a little more
self-determined a little more
self-assured little more stubborn than
Robert Downey jr. version of the
character you get the sense from a lot
of their scenes together that he treats
them sort of like a surrogate son but
really it's more like a big brother in
the comic book their ages were actually
much closer Iron Man still much much
older than spider-man but this is an
adult version of spider-man so it's more
like their frat bros Iron Man starts
tinkering with spider-man's costume
without his knowledge in the MCU version
he's really impressed with what Peter
Parker's done so far is this you kid wow
you could stop a bus you're really
strong how did you make this how did you
make the web fluid
he's a lot more impressed with
spider-man's natural scientific
abilities think comic-book Tony Stark is
so he starts building him an Iron Man
suit it just looks like a spider-man
suit that was kind of a problem with the
time because the suit definitely looked
badass but the color scheme was way off
it was a lot easier for him to make the
decision to take the costume off there
were a couple important decisions that
I'll explain in a second but it's almost
like Captain America wearing this Hydra
uniform that's not what Captain America
looks like this is what his costume
looks like the traditional colors so
what the movies have done is they've had
Tony Stark top-to-bottom redesign what
spider-man already did we're going to
take all these awesome ideas you had
collaborate and build something new so
obviously he added a lot of secret
functions that Spiderman hasn't unlocked
in the movie yet because of that
training wheels protocol he's in high
school of course you got to mind that
for comedy he doesn't have his driver's
license yet they also make that joke in
the comic book heat vision
nope rocket boots when you're old enough
to drive but then over the course of the
next couple issues he starts unlocking
the other abilities he starts fighting
titanium man while everybody's in
Washington debating the superhero
Registration Act doesn't that sound
familiar they're actually at the
Washington Monument in a lot of these
big action set-pieces
so even though the story the movie is a
little bit different there is a lot of
the origin of the iron spider in the
spider-man homecoming movie they use the
fight to show off the new arms surprise
they have all kinds of different
configurations they're basically a lot
like the extremis version of Iron Man's
armor they synthesize and deploy anyway
spider-man needs them he has all kinds
of different web configurations he has
the same Iron Man HUD that connects into
all the same systems that Iron Man does
one of the only things that he did not
have was an AI system unlike Tom
Hollands version of the costume so I
think that just sounds like Friday so
it's almost like Ironman just copied his
own AI system but the important thing
about that is the back door that Iron
Man built into the software so Iron Man
controls all of stark tech his AI system
Friday is able to track stark tech
anywhere in the world no matter who's
using it so if Iron Man loses a piece of
his armor and a criminal starts using it
or an Iron Man suit gets compromised and
gets used by some of his other villains
he'll know about it he
take that over control it through back
doors that he builds into his software
systems so a lot of you know during the
original Civil War spider-man has the
crisis of conscience senses the Tony
Stark has the wrong idea and then around
Civil War issue number five makes the
decision to split from him only the suit
is controlled by Iron Man so he has
trouble fighting him he runs off into
the sewers gets his ass handed to him
gets saved by the Punisher and then
officially joins Captain America's
Secret Avengers putting back on the
classic Spiderman cloth suit so back to
normal spider-man by issue number six
the story of the movie is all about
spider-man being this Avengers hopeful
but the suit does not make the Avenger
so Tony Stark is like in a really
heavy-handed way trying to teach him
this lesson and he slowly comes to that
realization himself he puts the classic
costume back on you see in all this
footage here he's fighting the vulture
working on some new moves
but he's still wearing his classic
costume so spider-man will become a hero
on his own steam in the movie but they
also want to show you how cool things
can get there's all these subsystems but
they're on lockdown I'm sick of him
treating me like a kid so much so all
those funny moments where you see
spider-man calling Ironman every five
minutes because he's an intern for the
Avengers technically Ironman knows where
he is at all times he tracks the suit
that's probably how he knows about the
ferry safe here because he senses all
the data that's coming from spider-man
suit in Friday alerts them sir Peter
Parker is an imminent danger there is a
giant disaster he plays it really cool
though when he pushes them out the car
here good luck kid I'm not giving you a
hug I'm just giving you a shove out the
door figured out on your own he cares
very deeply about spider-man that's why
he LoJack the suit it's almost like a
parent installing tracking software on
their child's cell phone so they can
track him all over town when they go to
hang out with their friends
the aftermath of this in the movies that
obviously spider-man's going to be part
of the Avengers during infinity war Tom
Holland just did an interview where he
talks about that so if you guys want me
to do a video about that I'll do that
tomorrow but in the comics it was
actually kind of funny like the conflict
went on things got worse during civil
war before they got better
Iron Man developed his iron spider
technology for a group of new people he
called The Scarlet Spider to sort of
replace spider-man
because he joined Captain America's team
just last year there was a really funny
twist on the idea to Mary Jane Watson
post Secret Wars became assistant to
Tony Stark in the absence of Pepper
Potts so she's basically the new Pepper
Potts working at the Avengers Tower Tony
Stark has sold the building and she
finds an iron spider suit copy inside a
box of things so she puts it on it has
to save Tony and Peter from a villain
called the region so they've been a
couple different people to where
versions of the costume there's a
version of Amadeus Cho from another
earth that's wearing a version of the
costume and then right now Doctor
Octopus is wearing a slight variation on
the idea of the suit he's called the
superior octopus but it's a Ben Riley
looking clone so let me know in the
comments which version of the costume do
you guys like the most
do you like the classic iron spider suit
the Iron Man colors do you like the MCU
classic color looking iron spider suit
or do you like the superior spider-man
look or the superior octopus look on the
costume looking ahead in the MCU what I
think I'll probably end up happening is
is they'll always stick with classic
spider-man colors like he's not going to
be wearing a different version of the
costume when we get to spider-man
homecoming 2 I think this will just
start unlocking those training wheels
abilities that you get the teaser for in
that footage so he'll always look like
classic spider-man even though the suit
will do different things so just start
unlocking other abilities that Tony
Stark built into it a long time ago but
congratulations to the new giveaway
winner Matthew Chung please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details
there's going to be some new flash later
tonight I'll explain how iris West was
able to defeat the person that she
defeated the finale just in case you
haven't watched the episode yet so while
you wait for that you can click here for
my non-spoilery Wonder Woman review and
you can click here for brand new
spider-man homecoming
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five see you guys tonight
you